und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend gleich wird wieder von dem
unvermeidlichen wiederkäuer die rede
sein der vom eis geholt wurde
praktisch bedeutet diese geschichte
menschen die nach 35 jahren arbeit zu
wenig rente haben werden eine
aufstockung bekommen diese unterstützung
stehen größere vermögen eigene und des
partners nicht im wege
nur zusätzliche einkommen müssen sich in
grenzen halten
das klärt die rentenversicherung dann
direkt mit dem finanzamt der bürger
braucht kein bit gang zur behörde so ein
kompromiss musste heute gelingen sonst
hätte sich die koalition blamiert da
waren sich alle seiten einig das heißt
aber ja noch lange nicht dass es dann
wirklich passiert aber es ist passiert
besprechen wir gleich mit dem
finanzminister vorher berichtet patricia
wiedemeier was die sache ist und wie sie
kam bei allen die heute morgen im
kanzleramt zusammenkam war der
einigungswille groß eine erneute
vertagung wieder keine einigung bei der
grundrente das hätte man niemandem mehr
erklären können
es ist ein sozialpolitischer meilenstein
die kuh ist vom eis
geeinigt hat sich die koalition darauf
dass menschen die 35 jahre lang
gearbeitet und in die staatliche
altersversorgung eingezahlt haben davon
aber nicht leben können
eine grundrente erhalten von der union
geforderten bedürftigkeitsprüfung soll
es nun eine einkommensprüfung geben
automatisch erstellt von
rentenversicherung und finanzbehörden
bis zu einem monatlichen einkommen von
1250 für alleinstehende und 1950 für
paare wird die grundrente in voller höhe
gezahlt
etwa 1,2 bis 1,5 millionen menschen
könnten davon profitieren geschätzte
kosten 1,5 milliarden pro jahr
damit ist aus meiner sicht auch die
halbzeitbilanz der groko abgerundet und
zwar perfekt abgerundet
aus meiner sicht gibt es auch keinen
grund mehr über den fortbestand
eigentlich zu diskutieren denn was wir
jetzt auf den weg gebrachte mass ein
echtes gerechtigkeit und leistungspaket
zusammen vier von fünf beziehen wenn in
zukunft die frauen seien und es ist
deshalb auch ein starkes frauen
politisches signal
zudem will die koalition den bei
prag zur arbeitslosenversicherung für
kurze zeit kürzen und
zukunftstechnologien fördern also ein
klares signal in richtung bekämpfung von
altersarmut sozialer gerechtigkeit
anerkennung von lebensleistung aber eben
auch wirtschaftliche dynamik die wir für
die zukunft brauchen während die
koalition sich feiert für ihren mühsamen
errungenen kompromiss gibt es die erste
kritik von der opposition
es ist so dass von den ursprünglich
geplanten über drei millionen jetzt
nicht einmal die hälfte
anspruchsberechtigt er bleibt und das
geht überhaupt nicht in ordnung
und ob die union den zustimmen wird ist
ebenfalls noch fraglich
das wird nicht einfach werden weil es
ein kompromiss ist und für einen
kompromiss muss auch in meiner fraktion
geworben werden wir werden da auch
überzeugungsarbeit leisten müssen
das erscheint wir noch nicht hinreichend
seriös gegenfinanziert zu sein also es
gibt auch noch offene fragen die wir
nächste woche beraten müssen der heute
gefundene kompromiss sei ein garant für
den fortbestand der koalition meint
dagegen politikwissenschaftler von lucke
die tatsache dass dieser kompromiss
gefunden wurde ist gewissermaßen die
grundvoraussetzung für den fortbestand
der großen koalition dieser ist aber
auch tragfähig denn er befriedet spd die
cdu und alle gegner in beiden parteien
die er neoliberalen in der cdu wie auch
die eher linken in der spd werden keine
möglichkeit haben dieses paket noch
einmal aufzuschnüren ob die kuh also
wirklich vom eis ist und ruhe einkehrt
in der koalition die nächsten tage
werden es zeigen und vielleicht dieses
gespräch aus potsdam zugeschaltet ist
der vizekanzler finanzminister und
aspirant auf den spd-vorsitz guten abend
herr scholz guten abend herr kleber für
drei millionen menschen wollten die sie
die zu geringe rente erhöhen jetzt
werden es nur 1,5 millionen menschen
und trotzdem lobt die spd das ergebnis
wollte die spd also ursprünglich zu
großzügig geld von rentenversicherten am
menschen geben die das nicht wirklich
bauen ein wir haben eine sehr gute
lösung gefunden die für viele viele eine
verbesserung zeigen wird das merkt man
ja schon an den einkommensgrenzen die
sie von dargestellt haben da kann jeder
sich genau ausrechnen dass er selber
gemeint ist und die gibt es ja auch
überall in deutschland viele männer und
frauen die wirklich viel gearbeitet
haben und eine viel zu geringe rente
haben den können wir jetzt helfen in
einer aufstockung und das bedeutet
übrigens dass wir in deutschland etwas
machen was es in vielen anderen ländern
gibt nämlich eine verbesserung kleiner
renten und das muss auch sein und so
erklären sie das auch den 1,5 millionen
menschen die durch den kompromiss von
heute jetzt kürzer kommen als sie das
ursprünglich wollen es geht ja um die
zahl derjenigen die wenig geld haben das
kann man und dem was sie eben
beschrieben hat gut sehen und ich glaube
dass es auch einen anderen maßstab gibt
der mich immer wieder sehr bewegt und
berührt hat wenn ich darüber in
deutschland gesprochen habe haben mich
viele angesprochen und gesagt sie
fühlten sich gemeint und ich genau
glaube genau die sind jetzt auch von
diesem ergebnis berührt und werden
verbesserungen für ihr leben bekommen
und zwar auf dauer also auch diese
anderthalb millionen menschen werden auf
die dauer die rentenversicherung eine
menge geld kosten
sie finanzieren das sagen sie mit der
finanztransaktionssteuer die es noch gar
nicht gibt spricht man da nicht von
einer luftnummer
nein das gesetz können wir in wenigen
tagen wochen auf die gesetzgebungs waren
bringen das ist gut vorbereitet wir
haben ja auch im übrigen überall in
europa mit anderen gesprochen so dass
wir jetzt ein gesetz hier in deutschland
in den bundestag einbringen können dass
sich genau in der linie der europäischen
verständigung bewegt das heißt sie
werden nicht auf eine europäische lösung
warten sondern erstmal wie frankreich
diesen schritt machen
ich gehe davon aus dass auch für europa
die einigung jetzt kommt alles ist so
gut vorbereitet dass das hier das
gesetzgebungsverfahren nicht aufhalten
muss aber dass wir gleichzeitig auch
hinbekommen dass überall in europa bei
den ländern die da mitmachen wollen das
auch passieren wird das finde ich ist
wirklich ein guter fortschritt weil wir
das auch immer sehr mühselig angestrebt
haben vielleicht ist das auch eine
botschaft über das was heute gelungen
ist über die grundrente haben schon drei
regierung verhandelt und es nicht
hingekriegt wir haben das jetzt
hingekriegt auch die besteuerung von
finanztransaktionen ist schon lange
gefordert worden stand schon zwei
koalitionsverträgen jetzt klappt
trotzdem hätte man natürlich erstmal das
geld besorgen und es dann ausgeben
können aber vertiefen wir das nicht
weiter wenn die bundeswehr die cdu in
der man jetzt einiges grummeln
über diesen kompromiss im bundestag die
mehrheit nicht liefern würde
hypothetisch dann wäre aber die coco am
ende oder das wäre schon ein ziemliches
ereignis aber ich bin ganz sicher dass
das nicht passieren wird wir haben uns
deshalb so viel mühe gegeben damit wir
etwas hinbekommen den man bei richtigem
hinsehen zustimmen kann
das geht ja jetzt nicht nur um cdu csu
und spd
es geht um millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger und es geht um solche die
wirklich was geleistet haben im leben
und den bisher nicht gerechtigkeit
widerfahren ist das muss ein anliegen
demokratische politik sein das zu
verbessern
da war ja jetzt heute sehr zufrieden mit
dem ergebnis hat gesagt wir haben das
geschafft das bedeutet jetzt kann
niemand mehr ernsthaft dieses pop
existenz der großen koalition infrage
stehen
sehen sie das genauso wir haben jetzt ja
eine bilanz der bisherigen
regierungsarbeit aufgeschrieben und da
fehlte die grundrente als etwas das ganz
ganz wichtig ist unbedingt und ich bin
froh dass wir es jetzt hinbekommen haben
dann hat die groko ja ihre haupt sachen
erledigt könnte man sie doch auch
auflösung so kam uns ja auch sie aber
dann muss man sehr wenig kenntnisreich
sein denn wir haben uns ja auch noch
ganz viele dinge vorgenommen
zu denen gehört zum beispiel eine
verbesserung für unglaublich viele
familien in deutschland wir wollen
nämlich erreichen dass die sachgrundlose
befristung zurückgedrängt wird damit
familien besser planen können und
sicherheit haben dass es im arbeitsleben
ein ganz wichtiger fortschritt wir haben
uns auch noch vorgenommen etwas zu tun
unmittelbar für familien zum beispiel
indem wir dafür sorgen dass es bessere
betreuungsangebote an den grundschulen
ganztags gibt alles sachen die jetzt
noch erledigt werden müssen die
umgestaltung oder die neue regelung für
arbeitsfeld befristete arbeitsverträge
versuchen sie auch schon lange ist ein
ziemlicher zankapfel auch mit der union
und mit den unternehmerverbänden auch
wieder so eine sache wo sie sagen da
steht die gruppe auf dem spiel
das haben wir ja sehr präzise im
koalitionsvertrag geregelt wie das kann
sogar dass er auch mit der grundrente
das war auch sehr geregelt und wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass im nächsten jahr
auf den weg zu bringen das würde dann
nach planen auch so erfolgen nun wird er
am ende des monats die entscheidung
fallen über den parteivorsitz können sie
jetzt nach der grund renten einigung
eine klare ansage machen die groko geht
weiter mit mir aber nicht weiter mit
meinen
bewerbern oder sollen die mitglieder der
spd in der hinsicht noch weiter im
unklaren bleiben
die mitglieder der spd werden eine
entscheidung über den parteivorsitz
treffen klara geywitz und ich bewerben
uns weil wir glauben dass wir dazu
beitragen können dass die spd wieder
stärker wird und dass wir was
durchsetzen können vielleicht ist heute
gesehen worden dass das auch geht und
das ist vielleicht auch ein guter
beitrag für die weiteren diskussionen
ein guter beitrag sie vermeiden die
möglichkeit jetzt ein klares bekenntnis
zur großen koalition zur fortsetzung zu
machen in drei vier wochen wird sich das
ja nicht grundlegend geändert
nein ich habe überhaupt nie einen hehl
daraus gemacht dass ich finde dass die
leistungsbilanz der koalition sehr gut
ist und deshalb bin ich auch sehr froh
über das verfahren das wir in der spd
dazu verabredet haben dass ich als
bundesminister der finanzen als
vizekanzler finde dass das auch ein teil
der entscheidung sein muss dass es gute
ergebnisse gegeben hat ist jetzt nicht
so verwunderlich und wahrscheinlich auch
keine neue nachricht wichtiger ist dass
wir wissen worum es daneben auch noch
geht nämlich dass die spd stärker wird
dass sie dadurch dass sie klare position
formuliert auch die zustimmung bei den
bürgerinnen bürgern bekommt die sie
benötigt wir brauchen keinen
zickzackkurs sondern eine spd die man
versteht selbst wenn man nicht viele
programme lange liest dankeschön und
einen guten achten haben und nun die
nachrichten von bund oder gas
frankreichs präsident makro ist am abend
von bundespräsident steinmeier in berlin
empfangen worden
anlass ist der dreißigsten jahrestag des
mauerfalls steinmeier dankte makro für
die rolle frankreichs bei der deutschen
wiedervereinigung zu einem essen jetzt
am abend sind auch vertreter der ddr
bürgerrechtsbewegung und bundeskanzlerin
merkel geladen
gewürdigt wurde erneut die bedeutung der
deutsch französischen partnerschaft für
das vereinte europa in einer welt so
steinmeier
wie immer unberechenbarer werde in
bolivien hat präsident morales nach
heftigen protesten gegen seine
umstrittene wiederwahl eingelenkt und
neuwahlen angekündigt
zugleich stellt er sich gegen einen
rücktritt den nun gerade auch der
militärchef des landes gefordert hat
morales hat
sich nach der präsidentenwahl am 20
oktober direkt zum sieger erklärt obwohl
wahlbeobachter und opposition hinweise
auf manipulationen sagen seitdem hatten
sich anhänger und gegner des
linksgerichteten präsidenten
auseinandersetzungen geliefert bei denen
mindestens drei menschen ums leben kam
in der niedersächsischen
landeshauptstadt hannover hat der
grünen-kandidat die oberbürgermeister
wahl gewonnen
billy twomey setzte sich mit knapp 53
prozent in der stichwahl durch damit
stellt in hannover die spd erstmals seit
1946 nicht mehr den rathauschef und in
mainz der landeshauptstadt von rheinland
pfalz hat der spd amtsinhaber michael
ebling dagegen die stichwahl um den op
posten gewonnen
in dresden hat die herbstsynode der
evangelischen kirche mit einem
gottesdienst begonnen
vier tage lang soll es um den weg zu
einer kirche der gerechtigkeit und des
friedens gehen ratsvorsitzender bedford
strohm rief zum einsatz gegen rassismus
und antisemitismus auf man werde
diejenigen zur rede stellen
die rechtsradikalen deckung geben würden
außerdem will sich die ekd auch mit
ihrer missbrauchsgeschichte
auseinandersetzen
dazu wollen am dienstag betroffene vor
der synode sprechen
japans neuer kaiser naruhito und seine
gemahlin kaiserin masako haben sich
unter dem jubel zehntausender menschen
bei einer prachtvollen parade zur
thronbesteigung ihrem volk gezeigt in
schwarzer
geschützt von 26.000 polizisten ein
weiterer glanzpunkt in einer reihe von
thronfolge ritualen die im mai begonnen
hatten als naruto sein amt nach der
abdankung seines vaters übernommen hatte
spanien bild heute schon wieder ein
neues parlament das vierte in vier
jahren drei mal hintereinander hat die
sturheit der parteien eine halbwegs
funktionierende koalition blockiert
heute muss es gelingen sagten alle und
die wenigsten glauben dass das klappt in
madrid kneipe kranker banker sind die
ersten reaktionen ähnlich wie das
ergebnis dass das spanische fernsehen
nach schließen der wahllokale voraussagt
verhalten irgendwann brauchen wir mal
klarheit ich sehe aber keine das wird
alles wie bisher
guck mal hier die linke es bleibt alles
ungefähr so wie es war
wie soll man sich denn da vorstellen
dass die sich jetzt einigen zur stunde
werden die stimmen ausgezählt und
fortlaufend aktualisiert die
wahlbeteiligung ist gesunken die
konservativen legen zu die extreme
rechte wird drittstärkste partei eine
regierung zeichnet sich nicht ab
dabei bildeten die die in die wahllokale
gingen eine große koalition die sich
klarheit wünscht
ich hoffe es gibt ein definitives
ergebnis das wäre wichtig für spanien
ich hoffe dass es endlich eine richtige
regierung geben wird müssen wir noch mal
wählen wäre das absuchen
die sozialisten von pedro sanchez haben
wieder die meisten stimmen bekommen aber
sanchez ließ bis zuletzt offen mit wem
er wenn nötig koalieren wolle äußerte
sich bevor die wahllokale schlossen wir
wählen jetzt und dann sehen wir uns das
ergebnis an und regieren
spanien braucht definitiv stadt liegt
sanchez schloss eine große koalition aus
ebenso wie sein konservativer
gegenkandidat tableau casado dessen
partei blieb auch am abend dabei den
wählern scheint klar zu sein dass es nur
die möglichkeit gibt cassano oder
sanchez die spanierinnen und spanier
haben gewählt bislang gibt es keine
anzeichen dass die parteien diesmal mehr
draus machen und dann weiß niemand wie
es weitergehen soll thomas warum raufen
sich die konservativen und sozialisten
nicht zusammen in deutschland geht das
doch auch also zwei drittel der stimmen
sind derzeit ausgezählt rechnerisch wer
wirklich so dass wir eine große
koalition derzeit die einzige
möglichkeit aber die eher
sozialdemokratisch orientierten
sozialisten und die konservative partei
sind ideologisch sehr weit auseinander
die ideologischen gräben sind deutlich
tiefer und breiter als das in
deutschland etwa der fall ist und solche
koalitionsregierungen kennt man hier in
spanien nicht anders als in deutschland
hat das hier keine historischen
vorläufer von diesem patt wer profitiert
davon profitiert und derzeit die extreme
rechte die ihren stimmenanteil in ihre
abgeordnetenzahl nach dem derzeitigen
stand mehr als verdoppeln kann
sie nutzt die schwäche der bisherigen
regierung aus und sie hat die krise in
katalonien ausgenutzt wir alle haben die
bilder gesehen und barcelona von den
unruhen im zusammenhang mit der
unabhängigkeitsbewegung und vox hat der
regierung vorgeworfen dort nicht
entschieden genug die einheit der nation
zu verteidigen hat deutlich drastischere
maßnahmen gefordert und hat so bei
vielen wählerinnen und wählern
offensichtlich gepunktet aber nicht
genug um jetzt eine regierung bilden zu
können was passiert jetzt können das
können doch nicht nächstes jahr schon
wieder wahlen stattfinden also viele
leute sagen das wäre absurd aber es ist
tatsächlich derzeit offen möglich ist
dass die sozialisten wieder versuchen
eine minderheitsregierung zu bilden so
wie beim letzten mal und dann irgendwie
damit durchzukommen
aber man muss sich klarmachen dass viele
menschen hier im land tatsächlich auch
darunter leiden also wir haben
beispielsweise mit landwirten gesprochen
die sagen wir brauchen endlich mal
klarheit es gibt keine investitionen
es gibt keinen ordentlichen haushalt es
gibt keinen adressaten für uns
die politischen forderungen so geht das
doch alles nicht spanien ist derzeit
einfach ein land in dem sich zeigt wie
ein staat leidet wie ein staat gelähmt
ist wenn die großen parteien der mitte
nicht bereit und in der lage sind
miteinander vernünftig umzugehen
kompromisse zu bilden und möglicherweise
eben auch eine koalition hängepartie in
einem der größten länder der
europäischen union dankeschön thomas von
aktuellen sorgen zu einem stück
zeitgeschichte heute vor 75 jahren hat
die gestapo in köln ehrenfeld menschen
zusammengetrieben damit sie dabei
zuschauen wie 13 menschen öffentlich
gehängt wurden
lynchjustiz ohne jeden strafprozess
sechs dieser ermordeten waren
jugendliche sie hatten gestohlen
lebensmittel benzin und waffen um
versteckten juden flüchtenden
deserteuren und zwangsarbeitern zu
helfen
der jüngste dieser schwerverbrecher war
sechzehnter der ältere bruder eines der
wunderbaren kinder lebt noch kann
zeugnis ablegen von einer jugendbewegung
nicht nur in köln ehrenfeld gegen die
nazis auch die junge bundesrepublik hat
sich an dieser bewegung versündigt und
ein ehrendes erinnern lange verweigert
silas hintze und ralf paletschek über
ein fast vergessenes stück geschichte
das erzählt gehört köln ehrenfeld
wolfgang schwarz fällt es schwer hier
herzukommen immer noch aber dem 93
jährigen ist es wichtig daran zu
erinnern was hier im november 1944
geschah es ist auch seine geschichte
hier wurden ausländer und meine freunde
erhängt
eine öffentliche hinrichtung von 13
menschen ohne gerichtsurteil unter den
ermordeten sechs jugendliche darunter
auch der 16 jährige günter wolfgang
schwarz jüngerer bruder
die geschwister waren edelweißpiraten
sie kämpfen ums überleben und gegen den
ns-terror versteckten juden klauten
lebensmittel stahlen waffen wolfgang
hatte glück kurz vor der festnahme floh
er aus köln köln ende 1944 eine stadt in
trümmern
in der endphase des krieges verschärft
das regime noch einmal seinen terror die
gestapo geht brutal gegen jede form von
widerstand vor auch gegen die
jugendlichen mitglieder der
edelweißpiraten es sollen viele gruppen
gegeben haben sowie die edelweißpiraten
tausende jugendliche meist
arbeiterkinder in köln aber auch in
anderen städten meist wollten sie sich
nicht der hitlerjugend unterordnen frei
sein ohne zwang unangepasst sie nennen
sich edelweißpiraten aber auch navajos
oder die schlangen bande
sie rebellieren überall im dritten reich
kämpfen gegen die hj und immer häufiger
aktiv gegen das ns-regime für die
nationalsozialisten sind sie kriminelle
diese edelweißpiraten geschichte hier in
köln war die erste und danach sind
überall solche geschichten entdeckt
worden man überall festgestellt h es gab
ja tatsächlich überall solche
gruppierungen die in ihren möglichkeiten
in ihrem rahmen in ihrer kleinen
gemeinde in ihrer stadt usw versucht hat
sich sozusagen aus diesem system
auszuklinken das war für uns schon
widerstand was ist das besondere an dem
was sie getan haben warum ist das wieder
statt
nur weil strafbar war bei ihr strafe
wäre wenn sie schon ab touren
doch auch nach kriegsende geht die
kriminalisierung weiter dem widerstand
der bündischen jugend wird die
anerkennung verweigert ihr fehle der
politische intellektuelle hintergrund
heißt es etwa in urteils schreiben ein
bild das sich erst vor wenigen jahren
geändert hat
damit der widerstand der jugendlichen
nicht vergessen wird will wolfgang
schwarz auch mit 93 jahren seine
geschichte weitererzählen egal wie
schwer es ihm fällt und an den ort
kommen muss sein bruder hingerichtet
wurde wo die beiden brüder zuvor lebten
wer sich weigert aus der geschichte zu
lernen ist dazu verdammt sie zu
wiederholen schrieb der philosoph
centern ja da sind vorbild und schicksal
der edelweißpiraten eine besonders
wichtige lektion
es gab gerade eine meldung aus bolivien
die noch zuvor hinpasst
die eilmeldung gesagt dass boliviens
präsident morales nun doch seinen
rücktritt im fernsehen erklärt hat
unklar ist noch wann die neuwahlen in
bolivien nun angesetzt werden
in der fußball-bundesliga hat borussia
mönchengladbach die tabellenführung
gefestigt mit dem klaren 3 1-sieg gegen
werder bremen der vfl wolfsburg verlor 0
2 gegen bayer leverkusen
mit dem auswärtssieg ist leverkusen auf
tabellenplatz 8 geklettert und der sc
freiburg
dem gelang mit dem 1 0 sieg gegen
eintracht frankfurt der sprung auf einen
champions league platz
bundesligist mainz 05 hat sich nach der
gestrigen 2 zu 3 niederlage gegen union
berlin von trainer sandro schwarz
getrennt einvernehmlich wie es von
vereinsseite heißt es war die achte
niederlage der mainzer der saison mit
nur neun punkten und dem schlechtesten
torverhältnis der liga steht mainz 05
auf tabellenplatz 16
vorerst übernimmt co-trainer lichtem bei
den para weltmeisterschaften der
leichtathleten in dubai haben deutsche
athleten gold und silber gewonnen
bereits im ersten versuch gelangen
weitspringer leon schäfer eine weite von
6 meter neunzig gold für den 22 jahre
alten weltrekordhalter aus leverkusen
kugelstoßer kappel als amtierender
weltmeister angereist verfehlte die
titelverteidigung knapp um 17 cm
doch 13 meter 87 sicherten dem 24
jährigen aus sindelfingen silber gold
ging an den usbeken an dieser stelle
berichten wir oft über kinofilme aber
fast nie über computerspiele dabei wird
mit denen längst mehr geld verdient als
an kinokassen
die beiden welten kommen zusammen
[Musik]
für den blockbuster avatar übersetzten
computerprogramme schon 2009 die power
von zoe saldana in die animierten
eine umwerfende performance aber immer
noch kino man sitzt im sessel und kann
nichts tun außer um die helden banken im
computer spiel schlüpft man aber in ihre
rolle siegt oder versagt das ist das
profitable geschäft der zukunft und
große namen des kinos leyen den games
ihr können und ihren ruhm
andreas garbe zeigt dass an einem neuen
aufsehenerregenden spiel video kojima
zeichnet eine einsame welt seine vision
von der zukunft besteht aus vereinzeltem
bunkern in denen sich die letzten
menschen verschanzen verbunden nur noch
durch kuriere die durch unwegsames
terrain laufen müssen um die menschheit
zu versorgen
durch quer als diese enorme wildnis
allein und fühlst dich so winzig fast
wie ein insekt im vergleich zu der welt
die ich umgibt
da drängt sich die schon ein gefühl der
einsamkeit auf der spieler schlüpft in
den digitalen körper von schauspieler
norman reedus dessen aussehen und
bewegungen aufwendig eingescannt wurden
mads mikkelsen tauchte in einer
nebenrolle auf sowie der regisseur
guillermo del toro
selten hat ein videospiel so viel
interesse bei filmschaffenden ausgelöst
auf einer podiumsdiskussion lobte der
deutsche regisseur fatih akin kojima als
cubric der videospiele und das training
als inspiration
ich glaube schon dass er so ein
klassiker unter den spielen da
entwickelt hat was das kino auf jeden
fall mein kino auf jeden fall so so so
beeinflussen wird und impulse geben wird
die aufgaben die der spieler übernimmt
sind dabei recht banal als kurier muss
ja pracht von a nach b schleppen und
dabei erst einmal lernen sich sicher
durch das terrain zu bewegen
wer viele pakete auf dem rücken hat kann
leicht stolpern aus dem gleichgewicht
kommen der spieler muss dann per
knopfdruck gegensteuern
auch wegelagerer lauern dem spieler auf
und eine dunkle bedrohung der
namensgebende gestrandete tot
besonders die atmosphäre des spiels
beeindruckt regisseur fatih akin die
stimmung der kreiert ist eine ist eine
pessimistische aber dennoch eine schöne
stimmung und es ist das ganze spiel
sieht so ein tunnel und du du du spürst
du die hoffnung ja sowieso ganz am ende
vom tunnel und ich kann davon nur lernen
weil ich entdecke diese ganze gaming
welt auch gerade
lange zeit waren filme und videospiele
wie öl und wasser sie mischten sich
nicht doch dann erlebte das kino einen
radikalen bruch durch die
digitalisierung
nun ist der entstehungsprozess und die
benötigte expertise für diese zwei
unterhaltungsformen fast identisch des
trading ist auch mal mühsam die fracht
zu verteilen zu transportieren und zu
verteidigen kann frustrieren
es ist ein skurriles und manchmal auch
eintöniges hightech märchen eine
annäherung von film und videospiel blick
also in die zukunft der unterhaltung nun
haben wir noch einen in den nächste
woche klimaschutz und wirtschaftspolitik
die grünen wollen zeigen dass das
zusammengeht ab freitag auf ihrem
bundesparteitag in bielefeld einst als
protestpartei gegründet wollen sie jetzt
einen staatspolitisch vernünftigen kurs
fahren so zumindest das ziel der
parteichefs bernburg und habe die sich
zur wiederwahl stellen abschied vom fc
bayern uli hoeneß ist als fußballspieler
und dann als vereins-präsident hoch
aufgestiegen als steuerhinterzieher tief
gefallen
2016 noch einmal ein comeback als
präsident der bayern
am freitag ist der schlusspfiff für uli
hoeneß 500 der jahrestag havanna am
samstag hat die hauptstadt kubas
geburtstag und blickt zurück auf eine
bewegte geschichte von den spanien
gegründet davon zeugt noch heute die
architektur der kolonialzeit aus den
sechzehnten jahrhundert in die jahre
gekommen aber ein touristenmagnet
geblieben und das wetter bringt uns in
dieser neuen novemberwoche zum teil zehn
herbstnebel und auch schon schnee der
montag startet teils sonnig teils aber
länger neblig trübe im westen wird es
zunehmend stark bewölkt nachmittags gibt
es noch etwas regen bei 4 bis 9 grad in
den nächsten tagen gibt es bei ähnlichen
temperaturen viele wolken wenig sonne
und vor allem im süden etwas regen in
höheren lagen schnee maria und heinz
werden hier zeichen in welchen reim sich
die journal redaktion auf die ereignisse
der woche macht es wird nicht langweilig
eine gute zeit und bis bald genannt
[Musik]